Trevor Noah who was was because he's
stepping down now or he's being kicked
out he should have been kicked out years
ago because he took the Daily Show over
from Jon Stewart The Daily Show was
whether you agreed with Jon Stewart or
not and he's certainly gone off the woke
deep end Jon Stewart subsequently from
The Daily Show but tons of people did
watch The Daily Show when Jon Stewart
had it Trevor Noah took over nobody
watched you never saw a viral clipped it
never became relevant in any real way
again so they finally got rid of him and
they obviously would have gotten rid of
him earlier had he been white but he got
his privilege points and that's okay
that's fine that's how these
corporations work uh I just wanted to
throw back to this moment because this
this sort of encapsulates what he was
this moment mocking Americans who were
complaining about lockdowns and you know
after hearing the story I would love to
see an American citizen and a Chinese
citizen sit down to talk about kovid
because you always hear Americans
talking about how they feel as though
they were oppressed by the covert
restrictions here yeah the Chinese
person will be like it was brutal I was
literally bottled up in my home beaten
up by the police and sent to a
quarantine Camp be like I feel you
brother this one summer I got asked to
leave an Applebee's we are not different
at all my friend we both suffer
smug to come you know it's it's so
interesting when you see first
generation immigrants that come to this
country to be so hateful of this country
this is sort of the ilhan Omar syndrome
right like she came here he came here
you end up becoming millionaires or
congress people you're you're so close
to like the seat of power and you come
here to make fun of people because they
wanted to live freely sorry uh sorry
Trevor Noah that we were not quite as
bad as uh China but you know what it was
far worse than being kicked out of an
Applebee's